[Music]
foreign
we will showcase the 10 largest space
monsters ever seen in live action movies
there are a few that you might be
familiar with and some that might be new
to you so let's get to it
at number 10 we have the hexagot the
space slug from Star Wars is the
smallest on this list of course there
are creatures which can be thought of as
space monsters but most of them are
aliens that are stuck in planets these
monsters here in this list are actual
space traveling creatures the hexagots
length is 900 meters or 3000 feet it
would be a bit longer than the Burj
Khalifa the Millennium Falcon which is a
medium-sized spaceship is seen as being
a bug or a fly compared to it
number nine we have Parallax once a
garden called Crona later corrupted by
the power he sought to control he became
paralyzed the embodiment of fear in the
DC Universe more specifically in the
Green Lantern movie it appeared as a
large yellowish murky Cloud that
traverses in space from one world to
another feeding on the fear of the
living creatures in planets it comes to
visit since it was able to cover several
blocks of the city it was definitely
larger than the hexagot number eight the
up Drew Jihad in the movie Hellboy of
Drew Jihad are depicted as the ultimate
adversaries although they are only
briefly mentioned by name these beings
possess an eerie resemblance to
developers and draw inspiration from
lovecraftian teams they are believed to
be enclosed within crystalline shells
trapped somewhere in the vast expanse of
outer space they were released for a
short period of time and boy oh boy they
were Beyond gigantic in size
number 7 the Suma verminath in Solo a
Star Wars story The Sumo verminath was
an immense creature that Finds Its
dwelling within the tumultuous
gravitational Maelstrom known as the
mall this Cosmic Enclave consists of a
treacherous Labyrinth formed by a
cluster of black holes the sum of
romanoth a creature of colossal
proportions manifests as an entity
adorned with numerous tentacles its
continents resembling that of a
Celestial jellyfish of asteroid
proportions
number six the Nano swarm in moonfall
billions of years ago Advanced humans
were almost wiped out by a rebellious AI
survivors Bill asked to create habitable
worlds across the Galaxy but the AI
swarms destroyed all except for one the
remaining Arc became Earth in the solar
system in the movie an AI swarm acting
as a predatory creature in space
discovered the moon and started to
destabilize the moon in order to kill
all humans on Earth the Swarm was miles
in length
number five ego The Living Planet the
father of Star-Lord and the first
Celestial to be encountered in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe he was the
main villain of the second goddess of
the Galaxy movie although he has an
avatar of himself as a human-sized
character his real self is actually a
living planet which is around the size
of the Earth's Moon his main goal was
the transformation of the entire
universe into a version of himself
remaking the cosmos
number 4 Unicron within rise of the bees
in that movie Unicron reveals itself in
all its awe-inspiring magnificence
indulging in planetary fees birthing
terracons and spreading dread Across the
Universe ultimately culminating in the
Epic confrontation with Prime and the
Autobots in Earth Unicron is seen as a
planetary Transformer with two horns and
large rings around him he is definitely
the size of earth-like planets even
bigger by a narrow margin
number three irisham in the movie The
eternals irisham known as the prime
Celestial is portrayed as a powerful
being who created the first stars and
played a major role in reshaping the
universe alongside other celestials
arsham form stars planets galaxies and
life across the cosmos to ensure life's
continuation he planted Celestial seeds
on different planets leading to the
emergence of new celestials and the
birth of new stars and life forms and so
on although he is seen as being
planetary in size he could manipulate
his size to be whatever he wishes it to
be
number 2 Galactus he is often portrayed
and depicted as an embodiment of cosmic
balance rather than a villain in a
traditional sense he is driven by a
primal need to consume the Life Energy
of planets and its actions are often
portrayed as a part of a greater
multi-diversal cycle in the Fantastic
Four movie he is not shown in his
humanoid form but as a massive clouds
traversing through space consuming
worlds as he encounters them he is seen
being around the same size of Uranus as
Saturn
and number one Vigor in Star Trek the
motion picture Vigor was a massive
entity and one of the most extraordinary
life forms ever encountered by the
United Federation of planets it
generated levels of power that only can
be dreamed of by the existing species of
that universe and it also threatened
Earths with destruction until it managed
to evolve surrounded by layer upon layer
of cloud formations The Vessel aspect of
vigor was enormous with even the larger
spaceship seeming microscopic in
comparison its core is 78 kilometers but
its cloud formation is
0.0013 light years in size or more than
12 billion kilometers
so I hope you have enjoyed watching this
video do hit that like button for
support and subscribe but most of all
smash that Bell icon for regular updates
on new videos here on this channel take
care fam